i've had a loss of light or a right of
light consultant can look at the
property to assess that and i'm going to
start putting into into position the um
the the relevant
the relevant legal requirements to to
raise that that case uh so beyond the
right of light um the
the the proximity to my property uh this
outside this this big facing two and a
half story wall is going to be only a
meter and a half away from my boarder
fence that's bringing the uh the the
wall four meters closer to our house um
and i consider that to be not acceptable
also if you look at the design you'll
see that the two houses complement each
other so the low single story face faces
into
the opposing properties uh so this
design i feel has been uh complementary
to the two new builds that are being
proposed but they're not being but it's
not complementary to the two houses on
on either side of the development
um in respect to the rest of the
residents you know um we we have
part of the uh proposal states that the
the proposed design is in keeping with
the rest of the street in actual fact
it's only in keeping with 50 of the
street you know they there has been some
um some some care taken to to to blend
the design with the existing houses but
actually this 50 of the street is
bungalows and we will be just destroying
the bungalow and creating two two new
houses um the parking is already tight
on the street so although there are
parking bays uh with with the proposed
design these will these will um
the the extra house will increase the
amount of um road parking and then and
therefore reduce the safety for the
children that play on the street
um
also you know in this time of climate
change i want to highlight that i don't
feel any consideration um has been given
to uh to
sustainability in the design that's been
proposed if you look at the line of the
roof i don't believe that this um the
suitable adequate space on the roof
lines of these properties to include
solar panels um and and i would say that
that that in itself is a as a must
within within the current kind of
climate situation we find ourselves in
uh also you know looking at the impact
on other residences then there's five
properties that are going to suffer um
extensively from loss of light and loss
of privacy beyond beyond that of my own
thank you thank you very much um there
is one speaker speaking in favor of the
application paul hughes uh mr viewer
okay just sits in front of the
microphone um
similarly you have three minutes to
speak if you do one overtime i'll just
uh politely ask that you wrap up your
contribution thank you
[Music]
okay good evening members of the
committee and thank you for the
opportunity to speak here tonight i'm
paul hughes i'm the architect and agent
for the submission i'm here on behalf of
my client hustle free homes to ask for
your support and approval of this
application in line with the officer's
recommendations
as outlined in the office's presentation
this proposal seeks to build two new
force four bed family homes in a highly
sustainable location these are to
replace an existing three-bedroom
bungalow
that sits in a generous plot and which
is more than adequately sized to
accommodate the proposed dwellings
my client has worked proactively with
the council's planning offices including
engaging in a pre-application process to
arrive at the scheme that you're
considering today
we sincerely believe that this is a
scheme which responds to and respects
the prevailing scale massing rhythm and
character of utree drive
it's a high quality design which will
complement without attempting to
replicate the adjacent arts and craft
style houses key architectural details
including the gambrell roof the
front-facing gable and feature bay
windows have all been adopted
the proposed houses also respect the
existing building lines heights and
widths of the adjacent and facing
dwellings
the new houses will each provide four
good-sized bedrooms and ample living
space at ground level they exceed the
minimum recommendations of the
nationally described space standards
the external immunity space to each
dwelling is generous and in keeping with
if not exceeding many similar sized
properties in the neighbourhood
care has been taken in the location of
the buildings their form and window
positions in order to minimize the
potential impact on neighbours amenity
policy recommended separation distances
have been observed wherever possible
and where they've not been adhered to it
is with good reason such as to ensure
that the proposal respects the existing
building line of the adjacent two-story
dwellings in line with officers
recommendations at pre-op stage
the proposed buildings will make a
positive environmental contribution to
the sustainable drainage system and
electric vehicle charging points
provided
ecological improvements such as black
boxes and high quality tree planting are
also proposed
the site is in highly sustainable
location with good working access to
both sale and sale more and their local
services and public transport links
four secure bicycle parking spaces and
two car parking spaces per dwelling
including the charging points will also
be provided giving future residents a
range of sustainable travel choices
as noted in the office's committee
report the scheme will provide a small
economic benefit through the
construction process the applicant
consultant and contracting teams are all
based in trafford and take great pride
in providing high quality housing in our
local neighborhood
as noted in the offices committee report
and subject conditions the proposal is
considered to be acceptable in policy
terms in terms of design residential
amenity trees ecology parking highway
safety and drainage
equally subject to standard conditions
the scheme has not raised any objections
from statutory consultees
we therefore respectfully request that
members of the committee approve this
scheme
thank you
thank you um are there any members
machine to open the discussion
this item counselor minutes
um just speed it all along a bit
actually i think it's a nice and quite a
nice development i think it's i
understand the need for for obviously
bungalows but you know we're going to
fit two
especially two houses i think that the
space is fine for tickets to fit into
i think four bedrooms are what families
needing and i think that it's a good
use better use the land
um
and it doesn't seem to
yes they are slightly bigger than other
houses on that road but then if you had
if other houses had extensions and
things it would be a similar sort of
thing so i propose that we um
we support officer recommendation and
grant thank you
thank you and counselor chalking
[Music]
is
thank you and council win stanley
uh thank you chair i should say i've got
an
awful lot of sympathy with the the
current residents because my first
reaction when i went onto the road is
this is not a great development but then
look at the plans again and i looked at
the
um
the size of the plot
and the idea that we would get two
houses on that plot for the price of one
bungalow so we get uh two more two more
family properties
uh which we desperately need
um and also the design of the buildings
is i accept the point it's not in
keeping with the bungalows which will
remain there but the design of the
building is in keeping with the the
houses on that road
and it has many things to um
uh to recommend it it's it's thought
through things like the cycle stores and
the
the charging points they're all good
parts of the design so i will be
supporting this thank you chair thank
you councilman morgan
thank you chair um i do get some of the
objections um i think particularly um
uh
to the neighbor number nine it is a
really big impact but i don't see any
planning reasons to reject it on the
basis um i know there was a few comments
about the loss of a bungalow and i do
i do think there is a point about that
we
run asian society and i don't think
there's anything anything but i mean
this is just not not the planning
regards but it's there's anything the
um impact on the fact we're losing
bungalows and that we've got an asian
society but i do think i do understand
the um
the comments that we made on that basis
and um maybe something that central
government will one day have to debate
um but i think um
it is a good use of space i think there
are good plans um i think four bedrooms
as councilmembers mentioned um is what
families now want and it's like i see no
reason to object to this i'll be
supporting it thank you
thank you and did share your point about
the loss of a bungalow i think did i
have a family member who has
accessibility requirements and very much
like a bungalow as i always sort of
grieve the loss of a bungalow and i can
understand why
residents on the street might
be concerned about the development
because it is a more intense use of the
plot than what what's currently there
but
just sort of skimming quickly through
the application the committee report
again it it seems to me the application
is policy compliant and i couldn't
myself
find a
grounds for refusing it um
are there any other members who wish to
contribute counselor thomas thank you
chair uh yeah uh
i actually think the gardens are wider
than the gardens of the properties to
the left which looked in
and well the parking issue
is a great one when i went to visit
there were many cars part on the
pavement down down that street
which is a bug bear of mine i'd like to
see three car parking spaces but i don't
think it's
a necessity and i can't see any reason
why not support it
has been proposed in second did the
um the supplication be approved in line
with officer recommendation are there
any members who want to contribute to
the discussion before we move to a
vote
no okay then um if members happy to
support the motion that permission be
granted this evening can indicate now
okay
um that motion's carried and permission
is granted and thank you to mr cross and
mr hughes for turning up to participate
this evening
and when i moved to application
106.076 217 woodhouse lane in timberley
and information of which can be found on
page 37 of the committee report
before we hear from speakers this
application is going to be introduced by
ms milner
because
okay thank you chair
and the next application relates to 217
wood house lane east in template
um the application well it's
the application is for retrospective
planning commission and for development
to the side of 217
and woodhouse laney is on the corner
with fairborn drive the application
property at ground floor is a grocery
store with a residential flat above it's
part of a commercial terrace and it is
the end terrace
so the
retrospective permission is sort for the
single story side extension
it is constricted of white upv
why upvc cladding and with a felt
membrane roof and a aluminium roller
shutter
um on the east as can be seen there on
your photographs and
we have received objections in relation
to the design
access and land ownership and however
we've also received uh written support
from council administer to the
application who has called it to
committee
all
representations have been duly noted and
considered
and whilst we have no objection in
regards to residential amenity and
parking we do consider that the design
and appearance of the structure to be of
a poor standard and not of the standard
we wish to promote within the borough
and specifically the materiality and the
sighting make it overly dominant and in
congress within the street scene and
therefore we do recommend refusal
thank you and there is a speaker
speaking against this application yazmin
sin
provided a statement which will be made
up by ms coley
thank you chairman um this is a
statement on behalf of yasminsin of 205
amb woodhouse lane east
um thank you for your email and
informing me of the hearing
unfortunately i am able unable to attend
i am not happy with the extension this
has been built unlawfully at 217
woodhouse lane east i found the
additional structure unsightly and it
also looks unsafe this was built without
the permission of the landowners and
also built before getting permission
from the council this trespassing of the
land brings detriment to the local area
and has also caused unnecessary upset in
neighboring relations
being opposite the school and in a nice
commercial area i feel the building is
unnecessary and doesn't follow the
character of the terraced block and the
brick what used the use of the ub pvc
cladding is not aesthetically pleasing
my concern is also not fire safe
especially with the previous history of
firing that property
along with tenants trespassing on land
that does not belong to them and also
knowing this when building this
extension i find disrespectful
due to this i find it was premeditated
to try and pass off the extension
without letting anybody know including
the council why was planning permission
not requested before building and why
continue to build the extension
when made it made a way that it is
illegal i strongly oppose this extension
thank you
thank you and there's two people
speaking in favor of the application
council of
have you decided to speak first
hi mr kumar if you can just sit in front
of the microphone you've got three
minutes to speak to commit evie one over
time i'll just politely ask that you up
with your contribution thank you
yeah thank you very much
um actually before i start this
extension i had a quite big space there
uh from my wall i have nearly more than
10 meter gap up to the road so actually
my extension is approximately 2.5 meter
which is under the boundary limit i not
go over my boundary limit and
that's that's the first point i want to
show you but
when i built this one before before i
built this extension
uh there is a people parking the cars
over there left right and center so
that's that was big disturb for the
pedestrian and the local community they
can't walk because the school there the
school and the kids the moms and dads
they are not able to walk there because
the people use as a public car park that
whole place when i build this small
extension that space is completely free
for the pedestrian so anybody can walk
through now it's a big space for the
pedestrians
of course i had this issue with that
before i contacted the council i said
people are parking the car i can't get
out is this there my fire exit is
blocked out and everything the council
advised me this is actually private
property you have to find some other way
to sort out this problem
second thing this shop has been last two
years uh is this is only very small
um shop in that village it it is really
helpful for the local community there's
a mixed community in that timberly
village
when this um
situation the shop is too tiny and the
people are queuing outside the customers
are queuing outside i need some space
that's the reason i just put the symbol
extension and just let the people in i
don't want the people standing outside
because this uh covet situation
and i spent some money to do this one
this is my personal money i spend this
money so this is this is a big effort i
did if you say something i got some
comments because they're glading and the
shutter if you don't like it i am
working with the planning community if
you say okay the shutter needs to be
changed different color or different
material i am i'm happy to work with it
and if you have any alteration also i'm
happy to do with the working with
planning committee thank you
thank you mr kumar um
councillor minis if you want to consider
my phone do you have five minutes to
address committee thank you
[Music]
thank you
so i when i when i called this um
into committee the reason why i called
it in is i mean it says it in there
actually um the reason why i called in
was i i was i was
uh and i don't think that it is actually
that unsightly although you know i would
appreciate materials and things people
may have different opinions on um and as
um jude said that he would happily work
with the with uh planning department to
to resolve those
um i also don't think that at all that
it um
is over dominant it's it's not that big
um it's a little lean to to the shop
um
and
if you i don't know how many of you have
gone to the corner of fairborn and um
with healthy news but there's basically
quite still a lot of the
before you get to the pavement part a
lot of land there's no sort of issue
with seeing around the corner when
you're driving around around um if
you're going to turn into fairborn
there's no issue with you know seeing
around it's not i don't think it views
it doesn't obscure any view to fairborn
to go round um so to me i don't i don't
i disagree that it's um as it were
intrusive at all i understand that the
color and whatnot may not be
you know
too soft to some people's liking but i
don't think the size of it is not
massive it's not it doesn't stick out
you know into the street people can
still walk around there's plenty of
space there
um
so this is why i brought it in um
and
regarding regarding the the ownership of
the land it's something i didn't
actually know uh when i brought when i
called it in it's something i wasn't i
wasn't aware of i thought that it was
owned by the um
the
uh landlord of the shop so it's
something i didn't know but that's not a
planning matter anyway the planning
matter is is the
you know the the planning application of
building the lean to storage area so if
everybody can look at that rather than
and make your mind up of whether you
think you know
about the what it's been made out of but
i don't you know i think it's a matter
of opinion
with a lot of these things thank you
thank you councillor um councillor
bunting indicated
thank you chairman
just before i give my comments on this
specifically i think we should arrange
some sort of prize for the council
officer who introduced this one
for the greatest use of understatement
that i've heard for some time this is
not of a standard of design that you
would wish to promote within the bower
yeah you're not kidding are you um good
god uh
it's an ugly little box shoved on the
side of a building without any kind of
thought or attention whatsoever and of
absolutely no concern to anyone who
lives or works in the area i think that
might be a better way of putting it i
mean i have no objection to
an extension on the side of this
property per se you know a properly
designed and built
extension
wouldn't necessarily have any concern
about that but this basically looks like
a box that seems to be remaining
standing although quite how it's
remaining standard it doesn't look
particularly sturdy in its construction
but when i went to have a look at it and
it's certainly not built to a high
quality it stands out a mile but
literally the moment you drive around
the corner you couldn't help but notice
it there was no
sometimes when you're doing your
planning visits you have a slight degree
of difficulty finding the site that
you're looking for there was absolutely
no difficulty finding this one i was
that was the one good thing i could say
about it
um i can't
possibly disagree with the reason for
refusal
it's
just not an acceptable build i i don't
see why the people who live in this area
should have to put up with that would i
want to build will i want an extension
like this put up in my wood well i want
it in an area that i had to go and visit
and had to work in would i want to look
at something like that on a regular
basis no if it's not good enough for my
wood why should it be good enough for
anywhere else in the borough if i
wouldn't want to have to put up with
this in my area why should the people
who live in this area have to put up
with it it's completely unacceptable i'm
i'm surprised it's uh the councilman
says brought this to try and defend it
this evening i think she's a valiant
effort counsellor but i'm afraid no
cigar i can't possibly agree with her on
this occasion although i do agree with
them on many occasions not this time uh
chairman i'm more than happy to propose
we accept officer recommendation and
refuse this ridiculous application thank
you chairman thank you i'm councillor
morgan
thank you um chair i'm gonna completely
agree with the sentiments that council
bunting's just said i i honestly i'm
really i'm amazed that we're actually
even having to debate it um i i
absolutely support officer
recommendations um this is exactly what
the planning process is there to stop
um what i'm surprised
has ever been thought could be um
reasonable in the area um i'm absolutely
happy to second council hunting's um
proposal to agree with officer
recommendations to
refuse this application
thank you council hartley indicates
you'd like to ask a question
yes uh please chat just to say my
comments on the application i mean i
agree with the previous speakers i think
i think it is a
a poor design and you know i understand
the
the problems the business owners facing
and and the applicant's facing and the
wish to extend the business but and and
that plot of land
um
is ripe for an extension but it but it
needed to be done away with using you
know materials that complement the
existing building and uh and then it
wouldn't look so out of place um
my question was around it is it is small
it's a lot smaller than the uh
in the garden house at turtle road
and
uh
i might be backing up the wrong tree
here but is is there a fallback position
of permitted development for
business premises
no okay thank you
thank you i did i think i agree with
what you said there comes the harley
the plot can accommodate um an extension
in the development i agree with what
councilman is have to say in that regard
is just
the materials used in the design of
what's been put in place counselor
welton did you contribute
yeah i have i have some sympathy with
council menace and i think it is uh it's
obviously served a very useful function
it you know
it's not a beautiful parade of shops so
therefore i don't think it stands out
that much
but having said that
just because it's not a beauty you know
a beautiful parade of shops doesn't mean
it doesn't deserve
a really nice extension and i hope that
you know i think i will agree that we
should refuse this and i hope that um
the the mr kumar will will
view this as hopefully an ex
a successful business experiment that
might
might then help him to go on and bring
us a much nicer extension forward that
the whole community can be you know that
can can be proud of and will actually
bring in a lot more customers into
into the shop and and i mean certainly i
i would agree that the current extension
he's built now is
more pretty than a car parked there but
i think he can do a lot better so i do
hope he will he will come forward with
something else thank you
thank you it has been moved and seconded
that
permission be refused for this
application in line with office
recommendation suggest that we move to a
vote
council minister
you're indicating me
i i think the sentiment is of
such false that i don't think a deferral
would manage to wire out the issues with
the with the development as it is
in time
um
counselor hassan
what what is the complication if it is
an extension there i mean
i'm studying the recommendation
it should be refused
and we have already granted a very
complex
application been granted
and
it is on the corner and this corner is
being used as a car park
now he wants to
utilize and use it
as an extension
for more beautiful space
uh it will be beneficial for the
community or it would be
what is the problem so there's more than
one grounds for
the recommendation that the permission
be refused um for me the critical issue
is the materials that have been used
okay if this were
a rhetoric extension that was consistent
with the existing building form i'd
probably be happy to approve it but
it's upvc clouded and yeah and it's like
it's not consistent with the other
buildings on site um so that there has
been a proposal um and and second
as well the
um permission be refused in line with
office of recommendation
suggests that we move to
if members inclined to support that
motion can indicate now
okay not motions carried um
the permission for development is
refused
now turn to application 104 760
sure view residential care home in
flixton which can be found on page one
of the committee report
um
there's no speakers to this item it will
be introduced by ms lowe's
you
thank you this application relates to
development at shoreview residential
care home and is for the installation of
solar panels on the roof
the site is um as you can see on the
site plant is a square site um
with trees and other vegetation along
the boundaries and is occupied by two
buildings a two-story structure to the
north and a larger single-story
structure to the south
you can see that on the visual um
bedside view and this is the property
where the um
solar panels will be installed and it'll
be on two sections of the roof here
on the eastern elevation and in the
southern elevation the solar panels will
project no more than 200 millimeters
beyond the plane of the roof
the key issue to consider is the visual
impact of the proposal
members should note that the application
initially included the installation of
air source heat pumps which have since
been removed from the application and a
separate application is considering
those
the application received objections from
four neighboring properties with
concerns relating to noise and the
maintenance of trees both of which are
not material to the consideration of
this application the application is
reported to committee and as the council
is the applicant the development is
considered acceptable on visual amenity
grounds and there are no concerns in
respect of residential amenity the
maintenance of trees is not considered
relevant to the consideration of this
application the application is
considered to be in accordance with
policies particularly at l7 and is
recommended for approval subject to
conditions thank you
thank you and councillor thomas
thank you chair this is my award i'm
very happy to support this uh it's a
small way of getting a little bit
greener in what is already a very green
ward
and uh happy to propose that we
accept the recommendations pass
thank you and councillor bunting just to
help out german happy second uh proposal
that's just been made i accept from the
residents some of the arguments yes
they're hardly things of beauty maybe
that's something for the green lobby to
try and work on how to make a solar
panel that doesn't look ugly that would
be that's something that could maybe go
with but
given the circumstances i don't think
it's anywhere near something that could
ever justify refusal and then more than
i could second it thank you
thank you anybody else wishing to
comment no because it's been proposed
and second did the application be uh the
permission be granted for this
application in line with office
recommendation if those inclined support
can indicate no
okay make that unanimous that permission
is granted one out into application
104 797 wood haze primary school in sale
um
that there are two applications uh
pertaining to this um site the first
one's on page eight of the committee
report
and be introduced by mr day
thank you chair um
yeah so this application relates to the
proposed installation
of solar panels on the roof of wood
hayes primary school
and the application has been reported to
the committee because
the applicant's traffic council and
objections have been received
the post solar panels will be located on
the south facing
internal
courtyard
sorry that's the
we've got the heat pump
one up sorry yeah
yeah size
yeah see so so you can see on that plan
that the solar panels will be located on
the south facing internal reef slope
although that plan's
north is
is facing to the right on that planet
and the south facing internal roof slope
um
[Music]
on the west facing external roof facing
onto the school grounds
nine objections were received but these
all relate to the originally proposed
air source heat pumps
which have since been omitted from this
application and obviously the subject of
the other application now
um let's consider that both solar panels
would be acceptable in terms of visual
amenity and residential immunity and
it's recommended that permission is
granted subject to appropriate
conditions
thank you councillor bunting you're
indicated
thank you gentlemen same comments as
before really pity they're not you know
again
it's pretty they don't look attractive
but given the location of where they are
you're not going to see them too easily
anyway uh and i don't think they're
gonna cause any particular harm so i'm
more than happy to uh propose that we
accept offensive recommendation thank
you thank you councillor minis
i'm happy to second it i don't i
disagree with it um because of one
thing's view on so the bit you know what
they look like i think they look fine
but there we go
yes thank you thank you councillor
winston did you want to contribute uh i
was going to second the motion
thank you is there anyone else who wants
to make a comment
no okay it's been proposed in a second
did the um permission be granted in line
with officer recommendation
and members have to support that motion
can indicate now
make that approval unanimous that
permission is granted we'll turn to
application 106 581 what day's primary
school in sale
information for which can be found on
page 118 of the committee report and
this application is going to be
introduced by mr dai
thank you this application relates to
the installation of two air source heat
pumps
a wood haze primary school um again it's
been reported to com committee because
the applicant's traffic council and
objections have been received
so you can see on the plan there that
the heat pumps would be located on the
western elevation of the school
at the northwest corner of the building
and within an external timber noise
protection enclosure
measuring 1.8 meters in height 1.8
meters in width
and 1 meter in depth
you can see the elevation
there
six objections have been received with
the main concerns relating to the
potential noise impacts
on nearby residential properties
the council's environmental protection
nuisance team has raised no objections
to the proposals
subject to the development being
implemented as set out in the submitted
noise impact assessment
it's considered that the first
development will be acceptable in terms
of visual immunity and residential
immunity
and is recommended that permission is
granted subject to appropriate
conditions
thank you councillor hartley
thank you chair i'm happy to propose
that we accept the office of
recommendation i think it's a welcome
application
like the previous two and
we're going to see more and more
applications like this obviously it
doesn't mean we should just approve them
all but um you know there is an
imperative to approve them under the
mppf
um where the impacts can be made
acceptable and this is a
perfect example of where it can because
of the um
timber enclosure which um mitigates any
visual impact and
the noise impact again isn't the
acoustic barrier will mitigate that
impact and uh
i think the um noise noise assessment uh
estimates it at 23 decibels and i
started to worry that might be as
loud as a hoover or a hair dryer but i
checked and 20 to 30 decibels is
equivalent to leaves rustling or
whispering at a five foot distance um
and obviously that's if you're outside
um
residents nearby will be will be inside
so i've no concerns about this and yeah
happy to support the officer
recommendation thank you thank you you
know i i i agree i think the critical
points in the report have been covered
pretty much in progress 17 and 18
regarding the um complaints faced about
potential for noise nuisance um
counselor stanley
yeah happy to second here my only
concern was to do with the um the
potential noise but the very
comprehensive acoustic re uh reports i
think what's the retention noise lower
than the current background noise so
there's no issue for this so happy 2nd
day thank you councillor morgan
very briefly um i mean they really are
quite having
seen these these operate they really are
quite quiet um i mean i will say i do
think they're really really really ugly
but um um and there's no i've not seen
any way of but this if we're going to
reduce the amount of energy we consume
as a as a country um it uses the inert
energy within air to use a small amount
of energy to get more energy it's about
four times the amount of energy um it's
we've got to start implementing some of
these sort of technologies um so um and
it really yeah it's really it's not it's
not gonna the residents are not going to
be able to hear it i know that despite
the fears um so yeah i'm happy to
support it thank you thank you
councillor bunting
thank you chairman um the only issue
would have been the noise issue was been
pointed out that's more that's a very
low level noise and acoustically not
going to be causing any kind of problem
also
in terms of visuals it's uh hidden away
within the uh
within its uh enclosure so unlike the
full mentioned solar panels won't be
causing a visual uh issue for anybody no
reason to refuse it more than happy to
vote for a chairman thank you
thank you um has been proposed and
seconded that we grant permission for
this
application in line with office
recommendation if members happy to
support that motion can indicate no
okay make that unanimous that that
permission is granted um that concludes
the business under agenda item six
gender item seven is um urgent business
i haven't been notified of any urgent
business no um and with that the meeting
this evening is closed thank you
everybody
how many leaves ben ruslan
you